did Will Smith just win the in my
feelings challenge I don't know but it
is new music Friday and we German then
[Music]
I'll be Friday my babies it is the
latest viral dance craze blowing up your
feeds and making me stay up past my
bedtime learning the damn thing
it's Drake's in my feelings challenge
that's comedians show / he started the
trend when he posted that video on his
Instagram and now celebs are hopping on
the bandwagon and taking this thing
global from Cape Town South Africa with
Ciara and Russell Wilson and Los Cabos
Mexico where dj khaled made it a family
affair but and only is really stead of
Graham yes we got a feel me of a funny
track to the set of this is us in LA
where sterling kate brown and his
on-screen wifey Susan Colette she Watson
took a break from filming to give the
challenge ago Graham yes we got a feel
me the footage I mean Academy okay but
then Will Smith took in my feelings
challenge up a notch when he scaled a
friggin bridge in Budapest showing the
kids how it's done
Oh Graham yes we got a feel me of a
funny trying him I'm me way to shut that
down Big Willie style you know even got
Drake's attention who commented wow the
video was done and by the way champagne
papi finally got in on the fun to doing
the challenge himself on stage during
one of his shows in lunch now this may
not be Budapest or South Africa but you
didn't think I wasn't gonna try to
challenge myself did you hit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright break your little sweat I
practiced that all morning for you guys
please if you're still here
don't leave there's more but I know you
liked it I know you did I believe you
got a move on because it is time for new
music Friday and the three new songs I
encourage you to turn up and turn out to
this weekend beginning with Ariana
Grande her next album sweetener is not
out until August 17th but lucky for our
inators she dropped the music video for
her latest single God is a woman and if
you listen closely God is actually
Madonna
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
and I will strike down upon thee with
great vengeance and furious anger those
who attempt to poison and destroy my
sisters and you will know my name is the
Lord when I lay my vengeance upon you
okay my daughter daughter does a rep for
re confirmed to ET the voice of God
there is AXI Madonna and Ariana herself
tweeted a couple of days ago to match
with the cryptic thank you you know why
and now you know why
alright guys but if you're going for a
more light and breezy summer vibe look
no further than childish gambino who
summons the nostalgia of the season with
his latest drop summertime magic
[Music]
Gambino paired this single with feels
like summer and clearly he's bettering
his odds for the title of song of the
summer but you know what here's a jam I
didn't see coming
21 pilots is back with a pair of new
tracks themselves including Niko and the
Niners at its groovy AF
[Music]
[Music]
they did that I'm coming into it but
what do you guys think which of these
three new jams got your attention this
week let us know and then check back
here next Friday for another batch of
new songs alright guys we are coming to
an end here I had so much fun
I went from crying this week to do it in
my feelings and I dare you guys to do
the challenge to just share the video
and rally the troops we'll be back on
Monday with another dose of the daily
Deni so I'll see you guys then